Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This is the way
This will be my Full Mandalorian.
Season three Episode three Video
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references. They also brought back
a bunch of characters
that we haven't seen since season two.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes
and careful spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet.
We'll start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments
and what's really going on.
Because there are a couple of cliffhangers
at the end of the episode,
a couple of big twists,
but I think they were pretty obvious
in the way that they were setting things
up and explaining
why characters were doing
what they were doing,
especially the shady comms officer.
Very shady.
The title of the episode was Chapter
19 The Convert,
which is meant to be a reference
to a couple of different characters,
a reference to Bo-Katan,
because now she's a believer.
She bathed in the living waters and became
part of Mando's Covert under the armor.
It was a reference to Dr. Pershing.
Now we know his real name is Dr.
Pen Pershing and the former comms officer,
Elia Cain, who seems like
she may have switched sides,
but I think that's a ruse.
I think she's just playing a long con
and she's secretly trying to break Moff
Gideon out of prison.
We'll get to that part of the episode
because she was playing
four dimensional chess
with doctor purging,
basically the theme of the episode,
though, is
that people are switching sides,
so to speak.
Switching sides in conflicts
like Mandalorian Faction versus
Mandalorian Faction, the Armors faction
versus Bo-Katan faction.
She has now switched sides. Now Dr.
Pershing
and all these other imperial characters
that were working under Moff Gideon
seem like they've switched sides
to The New Republic,
but at least one of them we know of
is probably lying through her teeth.
I'm not sure when they did this.
It might have just been
for The Mandalorian season three,
but they added Bo-Katan Night Owls
Mandalorian helmet to the intro.
I think that's why
they remove Kylo Ren's helmet.
Like they're just swapping
helmets in and out based on the series.
Katy Sackhoff also talked about this, too.
She said that after
they used her character in season two,
she didn't expect to come back
and be as big a character
in live action in future
Mandalorian season as she is now.
She actually thought
it was just going to be like a one off
cameo scene,
but it turned into a much bigger thing.
And now she's like one of the main
characters.
She's a great actress
and it's a really interesting character.
It'll be fun to learn more about if
you did not watch The Clone Wars episodes.
They really get into a lot of her
character during Clone Wars,
but you're really just
scratching the surface.
You learn a little bit about her
relationship with Duchess, the teen,
her sister in the other mystery
third sister.
We'll talk about that later
in the episode, too.
There is like a mystery
third sister that they never fully explain
during the Clone Wars.
But the episode begins with Bo-Katan
just stunned, silent,
thinking about the myth of saw
what just happened, what it means
about their ancient traditions, the creed,
all their beliefs. It's all true.
She's starting to believe again.
And she becomes a convert, so to speak.
Bo-Katan witnesses for Mando.
And later in the episode
two attesting to the other mandalorians
that he did bathe in the living waters
and has been redeemed.
He is officially a mandalorian again, but
he didn't see the missus or so he claims.
And I think he's being honest
like he was genuinely passed out
in Bo-Katan was the only one that saw
the missing sword.
She also claims the reason
why he fell so deep into that larger
cave is because of the bombings
that happened during the Great Purge.
Originally,
the cave that held the living quarters
was meant to be relatively shallow,
but the bombings just opened up the larger
cavern where the myth of Zeus lair
had probably been for all these years.
Mando grabs a vial of the living waters
as proof for the armor.
Also, we find out that the armor had
some secret living water stashed with her
because during episode one,
it makes the same reaction
when she pours it into her forge.
Even though they take off and Bo-Katan
makes no mention of the myth, this
or I think this is meant to be a big
cliffhanger for this particular moment.
They will come back
and eventually get the myth a sword
to help them or get like a baby mythos.
Or at some point
there will be more mythos or riding
like they did the Rain Corps with Boba
Fett during the book of Boba Fett.
They obviously plan to have Mando Bo-Katan
maybe Grogu also
writing a mythos or during
the Mandalorian series at some point.
You also notice
that when they're leaving Mandalore,
the way that Bo-Katan treats
Mando has completely changed.
Like the whole vibe is different.
She's way nicer to him, way more pleasant
just in general.
She invites him for a feast,
but jokes that he wouldn't
take his helmet off and to be pointless.
When Grogu reacts
by gurgling in this really upset
sounding noise, is him being upset
that they're not staying for an actual
feels like he wants an actual
peace like Kamala's stay.
Maybe
at some point they'll pay that moment off
where they share a feast together
and he winds up eating a ton of food.
It's like the Pedro Pascal meme
from The Last of US, where he just having
a panic attack, thinking about where
his next POG soup is going to come from.
When is Bo-Katan
going to make me some more soup?
When they go back to Calabar,
they get attacked
by a squadron of Thai interceptors
that we saw in all the trailers.
Grogu closes his pie just for protection
like he did during season two.
Mando jumps out with his jetpack,
gets into his neighbor's Starfighter,
and they team up like Bo-Katan
Mando team up to take them all out
pretty easily too. Like he says, no
scratches.
Bo-Katan
also jokes with R5 about being an all pro
navigating the seaside cliffs on Cala
Bala, which is meant to be the same vibe
as Luke Skywalker
referencing Bullseye Womp Rats with his
t 16 back in Beggar's Canyon when he went
on the Death Star Trek from Lagos.
Not going to be any problem at all.
No big deal.
Don't worry.
I grew up flying these cliffs.
Of course it's been a while.
Not impossible to bull's eye womp rats
In 96.
Back home, there always was ten years.
Then we see a squad of Thai bombers
destroy Bo Katan's family's
ancestral palace, destroying most of it,
which is meant to be a reference back
to the Great Purge, where you saw the
Thai bombers destroy the planet's surface.
It's meant to give her a bit of a PTSD
flashback to that.
When she calls them mud scoffers,
they're just meant to be a random
Star Wars insult that was used
by Cora Dune in previous seasons, too.
To have to publish a Star Wars
Urban Dictionary at some point.
There's so many slang terms, so many curse
words, a bunch more squadrons
of Thai interceptors
wind up showing up to chase them away.
So a lot of people
wondering about this, too.
Where did they come from?
Because the interesting thing about the
Thai fighters,
I mean, they're Thai interceptors,
but all these different types of Thai
fighters do not have hyper drives,
which is why they're able to get away,
why they can jump to hyperspace to escape,
meaning that they're short range fighters,
meaning that the ship that they came from,
the imperial ship was somewhere
in the Mandalorian system,
somewhere nearby.
I think these Thai interceptors,
the Thai bombers, the other Thai fighters
are part of Moff Gideon, former
forces in Grand Admiral Thrawn
seventh Fleet, which we got a teaser
for during Mandalorian season two.
Like I just did a Thrawn video.
The whole idea is that his seventh Fleet
has returned from the unknown regions
and it's way bigger
than the amount of forces that Moff Gideon
had access to before he was captured
at the end of Mandalorian Season two.
The other reason
why I don't think these are Moff
Gideon forces and they belong to Thrawn
is because when Moff Gideon was captured
at the end of Mandalorian season two,
they took his capital ship
and all the other lesser ships,
the tie fighters that he had with him.
So while these imperial ships
were to belong to someone else
and that someone else is probably grand
Admiral Thrawn.
The reason why he'd order
the tie bombers to destroy her palace
is because he's trying to sideline her
so that she can't rally more mandalorians
to challenge the empire
or the remnants of the empire.
It's all part of Grand
Admiral Ryan's master plan to sideline
any potential threats to him.
Defeating the New Republic
in the Mandalorians
would represent a huge threat to him.
So that's why he would want Bo-Katan
out of the way.
Then the episode goes back to Coruscant
and covers
more of the imperial side of the story
after the end of season two.
We didn't really get
a lot of these characters
during the book of Boba Fett,
so this is the first big
tie that we checked in
with our characters in a while.
You also remember that
we were just on course
on during the end or series,
but this is meant to be many years later,
According to Jon Favreau,
during the Mandalorian season
three, we're about nine years
after Return of the Jedi.
So during the episode,
they reference how The New Republic
has basically replaced all the imperial
insignia all over the place
and they're slowly mothballing
all this old imperial technology.
But generally Coruscant
is meant to look almost the exact same.
Dr. Pershing is giving a speech
to a bunch of New Republic senators
and really powerful people from the galaxy
that live on course.
So it's basically like all the same,
people came back to corridors, like, okay,
we're all still senators from our planet.
It's the same as it was before.
Just no Empire
New Republic banners everywhere.
Now in the speech
he's giving is all about reformation.
Like, I'm really sorry
about all the terrible things that I did,
but the Empire perverted my work.
I'm all about the advancement of science.
The same kind of speech
you get from all misguided scientists.
Like I only care
about the pursuit of knowledge,
even though it's kind of a morally murky,
gray area.
He confirms, We all believed
after The Mandalorian season one,
the first couple of episodes, we guess,
that he was working on cloning research
because the insignia on his jacket was
the same as the Kamino cloning facility
during the prequels.
He claims
Moff Gideon misused his cloning research
to secure more power for himself.
He also was kind of talking
about the emperor, too,
because he would have been around
during the original trilogy,
working under the Empire,
doing the same thing.
The whole idea that the Emperor
wanted to clone himself
and that's all about this Mount Tantos
project that they're teasing on bad batch
right now.
He was working for that group of people
because the uniforms that they're wearing
were the exact same type of uniform
that Pershing was wearing
in the first couple of seasons,
meaning that Dr.
Pershing
probably worked at Mount Tantalus.
And it's another heir to the Empire
Easter Egg.
I've been talking about
how they're doing a live action
version of Heir to the Empire with grand
Admiral Thrawn coming to the show
and then changing
a couple of the characters,
like the cloning plot with Luke Skywalker
during Heir to the Empire
is now the grogu who cloning plot.
But during this speech, Dr.
Pershing confirms
a lot of our theories in earlier seasons,
especially when he starts talking about
the idea of taking the different superior
attributes of different test subjects
to combine them
to make something even better.
That's all about Moff Gideon and Grand
Admiral Ron's plan, their grand plan
to create for sensitive clone troopers.
It would essentially give them a nice,
invincible army.
But the idea now is that
he's trying to win
over the New Republic Senate
and these other powerful people
in the New Republic.
So they won't throw him in prison and
they'll let him continue on his research,
which they claim is very illegal
under New Republic law in Khorasan.
You also notice the nervous tic
that he has there.
I don't know if he's always had that
or if he just recently developed it.
But any time he starts to get
really upset, he starts grabbing his ear,
you see, and do it again.
Later in the episode,
when the rehabilitation droid starts
asking him the same questions like,
Are you upset with The New Republic?
And he starts grabbing his ear like,
Yeah, I'm starting to get a little upset
when he talks about his back story
during the episode too.
Like during this scene
when he references his mother dying
and how cloning could have saved her.
I think that's all meant to be genuine.
Even later in the episode
when the comms officer starts
honey plotting him
and trying to get him arrested on purpose,
when he's talking to her about his mother
and his childhood, growing up,
dreaming of a lab like this, it's
all meant to be very naive and genuine.
Like he doesn't care about Empire
or New Republic.
He just wants to advance science
for the betterment of the human race.
In the tragedy of that,
as in all stories like this, is
that his work will be perverted
by more powerful people,
mostly in Thrawn, in Moff Gideon
trying to create for sensitive troopers.
The other funny Easter egg here to
some of you may have picked up on this
vibe is is the area
they're in here where this speech is being
given is meant to be the same place
where Palpatine had the infamous meme
worthy speech with Anna and Skywalker.
That's more of a callback to the idea
that Palpatine
was trying to find a way to clone himself.
And that's what he was
using this technology for
when he was talking to Mannequin Skywalker
about finding the secret to cheat death.
Turns out
he was just talking about cloning.
When Dr.
Pershing references
the first cast rejecting his formula.
That's a reference to the failed test
subjects back on Navarro that we saw
during season two.
In the whole conversation
he has with this group of centers
is meant to feel kind of slimy, like
they were people that Monmouth was talking
about during the and or series
that really only cared about
preserving their own power,
profiting off of their positions,
and they make it sound like they're
interested in his cloning technology
so that they can preserve their own lives.
Like Palpatine was trying to do, like
so that they can stay in power forever.
So the whole idea here and later
in the episode is they want to make
The New Republic feel like it's
not that different in a bad way to like,
it's just as shady as things
were under the empire for the most part.
Maybe things are just a little bit better,
but still, during the episode
they wanted to make large portions
of The New Republic seem really shady.
We're not torturing you.
This is totally different.
The dosage is so much lower.
But yes, it is kind of like torture.
The speeder that he rides in across
the city is meant to seem similar
to the yellow one that Anakin and Obi-Wan
had during Attack of the Clones.
When the Droid references
the Manta bag of Alistair.
That's an airborne blanket shaped predator
that smothered its prey, its reference
during the Star Wars role playing game.
There are a lot of deep cut references
like that during the episode.
It's also meant to be a sly
wink at the idea of the mythos, or which
they'd previously believed to be extinct,
which we know is still alive.
When he goes back to the amnesty housing
projects where they're putting him up.
Now either former Imperials use the slang
word PUTU, which is from the prequels.
It's just another Star Wars word for poop,
and they genuinely seem
like a pretty decent bunch.
With one exception.
They share a drink.
They joke about how things are really
no different under the New Republic.
Like, Yeah, we're glad the Empire is gone,
but really it's not that different.
He does seem kind of antsy
about associating with former Imperials
like he genuinely did not like.
Working for the Empire.
Doesn't
want to have anything to do with them.
And we find out the former comms officer
also lives here and is there basically
to try and eventually lead him
to the Star destroyer to get him arrested.
I'll explain that in a second, too.
But everything she was doing in
the episode was to further the goal
of getting him arrested.
The other joke here
about the number designations
all their names, is that the Empire
used to do that, to dehumanize them.
Like all Stormtroopers
just went by their number designations.
They didn't actually have real names.
It's just another way to show you
that things are no different
under The New Republic.
It's also meant to feel very dehumanizing.
Like a lot of Dr.
Pershing's actually, daily
work is meant to give you a lot of vibes
for the Cyril Khan character
during the Andor series.
Most Underappreciated Genius
living in the New Republic.
Currently.
Later in the episode, we find out
her name is really Elliot Kane,
which I think is her being honest.
They didn't give her a name
in previous seasons,
so this is like a brand new thing
for this season as a bit of a retcon.
And she references
that they both used to work for.
Moff Gideon, the other former Imperials,
also make it sound like everyone believes
that he escaped en route
to a New Republic War tribunal
and they don't know where he is.
Like nobody in the public
knows where he is, but secretly they imply
that the New Republic may have just
taken him to conditioning to a mind flayer
to pull more information out of his brain
like they do at the end of the episode.
I think the end of the episode
also kind of confirms
something similar happen to Moff Gideon,
and I think that's why
Elliot Kane, the comms officer, is doing
what she's doing in the episode.
The mind players that they reference
is a callback to Rogue One,
which is a creature that just literally
rips information out of people's brains.
When Pershing claims that he misses
the ration biscuits that the Empire used
to hand out in the outer
rim, later they pay that off
when Elliot King gives him a bunch.
She also references the core worlds.
That's where course on is.
It's where
the old power of the galaxy resides,
like the oldest, wealthiest planets.
Basically.
Later in his apartment,
we get all kinds of facts about Khorasan,
talking about the world
as an IQ monopolist
that literally just means a city
encompassing the entire planet.
If you didn't realize
that Khorasan is a citywide planet,
it's meant to be many,
many thousands of years old like it's
been many, many thousands of years
since you could actually see
the planet's surface.
They get into this during the Clone
Wars, too.
What happens
is that over the thousands of years
when they want to build more city,
they'll just build another layer
on top of the old city.
So it just keeps building up and up and up
and up in all the lower levels is
where all the criminal activity happens.
Like all the really shady stuff.
There was a scene during Andor
where Luthien actually goes down
to the lower levels
to conduct some shady business
with one of his informants,
and it probably wound up
being one of the greatest speeches
in all of Star Wars too.
That was a great episode of Andor
When the recording starts talking about
Khorasan is the center of the galaxy
is more of a metaphor.
That's the idea
because it used to be the capital.
It's not the physical center
of the galaxy, the planet that is closest
to the actual physical
center of the galaxy is BIS,
which used to be one of the Empire's home
bases, especially in legends canon.
It's a planet that's
bathed in the dark side of the force,
like very powerful in the dark side.
The reason why I think they made
that reference specifically
is because during the Dark Empire
storyline, this is where the Emperor kept
all of his clones
in Doctor Pershing's whole storyline
is about cloning for sensitive beings.
It be really cool.
They brought some of that stuff
from Dark Empire back into the canon.
Like I said earlier, the cubical
that they have him working in his day
job is meant to give you a lot of vibes
for zero Car and during and awe.
Same basic principle of just wasting away
at the most boring job
ever archiving information all former
imperial technology really useful stuff
that's being scrapped
that they're basically throwing away
when his coworker references
Ben Doo de Ben do was a creature
from Star Wars rebels.
He lived on the planet
add a lot and claimed
to represent the center of the force
between the light side and the dark side
and gave Kanan Ezra Bridger lessons
and the true nature of the force.
He was also voiced
by probably the most famous doctor
who from classic Hu Tom Baker,
another grand Admiral Thrawn, Easter Egg.
Grand Admiral Thrawn
wound up facing the men who eventually
the band who even saw a vision
of Thrawn future and told him.
But the whole idea is the BND
was meant to be much more powerful
than a traditional Jedi
or Sith because he wielded
both the dark and the light,
which I think they'll get into
with Grogu's storyline.
Like,
the whole idea is that he won't follow
the traditional Jedi path, like he left
Luke Skywalker Skywalker's Jedi Academy
and he will seek his own path
as the force.
Kind of like Ahsoka is doing,
and he'll wind up wielding the force
in a more complete way,
like a more holistic way than the Jedi,
or this is did in the past
The other Big Ben due east right too
is the Bendy who was originally the name
that George Lucas wanted to use
for the Jedi.
Later he changed the name to Jedi
in the script for a New Hope.
You notice they use another AR five Droid.
This delivering him
more archive information to be destroyed.
He goes on the tour of the city
that Eliakim offered him and it lists off
a whole bunch
more facts about the actual city itself.
Like it's
a bit of a tour guide for the city.
Like, did you know that over
a trillion people live on this planet?
She claims that she went to the Imperial
Academy on course and she's coming back.
But it feels different
because it feels much less hopeful.
The idea here is
that she's trying to drop him hints that,
Oh, no, no, I hate the New Republic.
I'm still sympathetic to the Empire.
You kind of get that vibe from her.
Like she's definitely feels kind of shady
and tries to get him to admit
to feeling underappreciated.
Think about how many people
your work could help
then when they see core science
version of Mount Everest
sticking out from the planet
like a monument.
I think this is meant to be the first time
we've actually seen a physical piece
of the course on planet.
Every time you see it in the Clone Wars
during Star Wars Rebels
during the other movies,
you're only just seeing the actual city
that was built on top of the planet.
So the tip of the mountain here
that he almost touches
is meant to be a metaphor for himself.
Like it's meant to feel insignificant
now in this giant cityscape.
Of course, what it's become in
present day, he feels so insignificant
in this giant new republic
when he has all these great things.
He could be doing
both of the scenes with the rehab droid,
This one and the one later in the episode
gave me Blade Runner vibes
when it referenced
the course on the accords.
Those were also written
after the end of Return of the Jedi
when the Empire was defeated in the New
Republic, evolved out of the rebellion.
The next morning at his job, he starts
asking about the stuff is getting junk
like all this is good technology.
We could just repurpose this.
I could show them how to use it.
He finally gets so upset
that he finally agrees
with Elia Kane to go find his lab
equipment inside a star destroyer.
The other interesting thing here, too,
that we find out
is that the person says
they're also scrapping.
They're junking the former
old rebellion fleet like they're
getting rid of all those capital ships
you saw during the original trilogy.
All that stuff seems really useful.
So it's like The New Republic
is getting rid of all the old stuff,
even the old rebel stuff,
like why are you throwing away
all this good stuff?
We could use this for so many things.
You also notice when he starts
eating the biscuit rations again,
they have the imperial insignia on them
and his nervous tic comes back
the second time he visits the rehab
droid like, okay, finally, now is enough.
The funny thing about him,
reassuring himself of what he's doing in
the mirror is the whole idea behind
misguided scientists like this is all
meets the same and like
they all have to talk themselves into it.
Like I'm doing this for a good reason.
This thing that's kind of shady.
Fundamentally, he's meant to be a tragic
character, like he wants to do good,
but he has trouble
bringing himself to do that
just because he's so focused
on his goal of science.
He's not really thinking
about the bigger picture.
Someone's definitely going
to use your cloning research
for something really shady eventually.
Then, when he finally agrees
to go with her, they go to the station.
The guards looking at him
funny are doing so
because she already tipped them all off.
They're all just waiting for it to happen
so they can arrest him
once he mentions tongs.
Days. Tongs Day was meant to be
the third day of the week.
Wednesday, which is the day that they air
New Mandalorian episodes
within the Star Wars universe.
So the day is named for Tongs,
which is a species
that was native to Khorasan.
There are more facts
about Coruscant in this episode
than I think we've gotten in
any of the Star Wars movies before.
It was kind of like a quick tour
guide of the city where you get a quick
history of the planet as well.
They jump off the back of the train
to avoid the ticket droid no tickets,
a bit of an Indiana Jones Easter egg.
There We have Indiana Jones five
that's coming out later this year, too.
It's also Lucasfilm like Star Wars,
and they wind up at the scrap yards
where they're decommissioning
all of the old Imperial Star destroyers
that they were able to capture.
The last big battle that the rebels
fought against the empire was at Jakku
in most of the imperial fleet.
The survived was actually hijacked
by one of the other officers
and taken to the unknown regions
to become the first order.
So the rebels only gained control
of a portion of the old imperial fleet,
not the entire fleet.
Also, there's the idea that Thrawn
has the Seventh Fleet.
It's completely intact.
It's a whole separate thing.
So there's still a lot of imperial capital
ships
of star destroyers
that are active out there.
But the lab equipment
that they go to find inside
the Star Destroyer is something
that you would find in any star destroyed.
Like it wasn't his specific lab equipment,
it was just random lab equipment.
And the whole joke here is
that it's all perfectly working.
Like everything in the lab
still has power. It all
looks really expensive and really useful,
and they're just going to junk it.
She continues to butter him up.
A bit of a honeypot situation here.
She also reveals
her real name is Elia Cain.
That might be an Easter egg for Tom Kean,
who was one of the voices on Star
Wars, the Clone Wars.
Dave Filoni may have given her the Kay
name in honor of him. Dr.
Pershing reveals
that his real name is Pen Purging.
Then the New Republic Guards show up to
arrest him and she shows her hand like up.
Sorry.
Sorry about this,
but I kind of led you along.
And you notice another big Easter egg here
for Previously on The Mandalorian
and for The Clone Wars is that Matt Lanter
character comes back.
This is meant to be Matt
Lanter playing the same character
that he did during the Mandalorian Season
one, the same New Republic officer
who used to work on the prison ship.
His character
didn't have a name during season one,
but he's meant to be the same person
as he was before.
He was the voice of Mannequin Skywalker.
More famously during the Clone Wars.
They have stealth cameo scenes like this
all the time
in all kinds of Star Wars
episodes, movies all over the place.
Mark Hamill has said that
he's done it many, many times.
I've talked about some of his stealth
cameos in my previous episode videos,
and usually when they do that,
their cameos will go uncredited.
So you only know if you recognize them
or if you recognize their voice
or if they tell you after the fact.
Sam Witwer did the same thing
during Star Wars and or where
he's like, Yep,
I was that Imperial Guard there.
That was me.
But he wasn't anywhere in the credits.
When he gets arrested,
they take him to the reconditioning center
that they referenced earlier
and they use a mind flayer like devise
a torture
like device on him to get him to forget.
Now, the way
the mind calamari talks about it,
they tune the dosage way down,
but it's meant to work
like the mind Flayer did during Rogue One
and they can use it.
In addition
to pulling information out of people,
they can use it to make people
forget things too.
He claims it's very pleasant now.
They turned the dosage way down
and it's not going to be that big a deal.
But when the light canes coworker
takes off, she cranks the dial way,
way up, so it's way more painful
and he starts forgetting way more things.
I think this is all part of our long plan
to break moff getting out of prison.
And what she's doing here is he's trying
to make him forget about everything
they talked about together,
going back days and days and days
so that when he comes out,
he'll just forget they ever met in her.
A grand plan is to advance her career
by throwing him under the bus
so that she'll get promotions
and allow her to get closer
to where they're holding Moff Gideon
secretly in a similar type of facility,
and she'll be able
to break him out of prison
because right after this,
she takes a bite out of the biscuit,
just letting you know
that she has definitely not switched
sides.
She is definitely still hardcore empire.
So she's going to be Moff
Gideon Escape ticket
because John Carlo Esposito said that Moff
Gideon has a huge rally
this season and I think she is the path
to that feel kind of bad for Dr.
Pershing now, even though he probably did
some really shady stuff
when he was working in the Empire
at Mount Tantas.
Then we jump back to Mando and Bo-Katan,
who's taken her to his covert,
reminding her
to keep her helmet on for etiquette.
They're met by the heavy infantryman
Paz Vizsla,
which is meant to be a huge reference
back to the Clone Wars.
Maybe she knew him when they were
both part of the deathwatch.
But the bigger Easter egg here is that
previously used to be her commander
and she followed him in Death Watch.
And he's either Paz Vissel, his father,
or his relative, or somehow
they're related.
So there is a connection there.
Like they might have been part
of Deathwatch together under previously,
but they're both characters
that were voiced by Jon Favreau.
So Katee Sackhoff is having another scene
with another Vizsla character
voiced by Jon Favreau.
He identifies her as a night owl
because of the markings on her helmet.
Those are the markings
on all the banners in her throne room.
She had those back during the Clone Wars
episodes.
Two The Night Owls originally started
as a hardcore group of female fighters
when she joined the Death
Watch Mandalorians, and previously
they joined with her.
When she left, they left with her
to when he calls her an apostate.
Her house has fallen.
She bathes in the living waters again too.
So she was re
baptized, redeemed, just like Din
Djarin wears the armor later recognizes.
So the joke is, is that
she's not an apostate anymore.
And when the armor recognizes
that she was redeemed,
she also invites her
to join their convert,
become part of their clan
as long as she keeps her helmet on.
Katy Sackhoff also talked about this, too.
The whole idea is that Bo-Katan had
basically been alone on her home planet.
Their uncle Abala,
she lost her family, so to speak.
The other night, Owls took off
when she came back without the darksaber.
And now, because of what's happened
recently, she's starting to believe again.
And she just gained another family.
The thing that she's wanted.
For those of you that are wondering
now if Bo-Katan is going to get together
with Mando and be like space
mom and space dad to grow too.
Technically,
she's not allowed to take her helmet off
right now, and neither does Din John.
Like, he's like, No, no, I'm
a mandalorian again.
I'm never taking my helmet off again.
By their customs.
Married couples,
like as part of their covert
can take their helmets off
when they're alone together.
Like when they're getting it
on, they can take their helmets off,
but only if they become a married couple.
I do think, though, eventually,
at some point in The Mandalorian,
we will see the armor take her helmet
off, though.
I think that's the other side
of this coin, too.
Like Bo-Katan has been rebel ties.
She is converted, so to speak,
like the title of the episode The Convert.
But the flip side of that
is that the armor will also chill out
just a little bit over
the future of the series,
and eventually
she'll take her helmet off too.
You also notice that the armor knows
exactly who Bo-Katan is
without her having to introduce herself,
unlike the past Vizsla character, like,
Oh, I know exactly who you are.
There are a lot of people
that are now wondering
if the armor is secretly Bo-Katan sister
or related her in some way.
There was a mystery third sister
that Bo-Katan and Satine had
because Korkie was their nephew.
That means there had to be another sister.
I don't know necessarily
that Dave Filoni would take this route,
but they could say that the armor is
that mystery third sister without having
to bend over backwards too much.
But even if they are not related,
I think the armor and bo-katan
will have some other history
that we'll learn about eventually.
So the big takeaway from the episode
is that there is a mystery imperial force
out there, like I said, is
probably Ron's fleet, the Seventh Fleet,
Ally Cain, the former comms officer.
It seems like she's en route
trying to break Moff Gideon out of prison,
slowly working her way closer to him.
And now Mando and Bo Katan's.
main mission is to rally more
mandalorians to their cause.
Go find the other mandalorians
the night owls that left bo-katan
that deserted her
after she came back with the darksaber
like, No, no, we have it now.
We're re baptized. We've all the way.
It was a great episode.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My Season three Episode four Trailer video
we'll post tomorrow in my full episode
for video we'll post next week
after they release it.
Everyone click here for that
episode for video at the link.
As soon as I post that and click here
to learn what's going on with Grand
Admiral Thrawn and what happened to him
after Star Wars Rebels.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe and this is the way.